The first one, 4n²-300n+12 € O(n²) because n² is the fastest growing term.  So it's correct.
And it's also the best possible bound because we have n² here as the fastest growing term,
which is exactly the same that we wrote here.
The second one is also correct because n³ grows faster than n², but it's not the best possible bound
we can give because we already found out that n² is the best possible bound that we can give.
Now down here 3ⁿ+5n²-3ⁿ grows much faster than n² so this is not true and of course it cannot be the
best possible bound if it's not a correct bound at all.
In the next one, 3ⁿ is the fastest growing term and this is exactly what we're setting on the right here
so it's correct and it's also the best possible bound that we can give.
The next one, again, the bound is correct.
This is similar to here when we compared n³ to n²
so 4ⁿ grows much faster than 3ⁿ, but again, it's not the best possible bound
because we already know that 3ⁿ is the best possible bound that we can give.
This one down here is similar to one of the examples that I just showed you,
so we can ignore the constant here and 2ⁿ(n²) grows faster than 2ⁿ so this is not correct.
And since it's not correct, it cannot be the best possible bound.
Now, this one down here is probably a little bit tricky because 2.1ⁿ indeed grows faster than
2ⁿ(n²) so if you plot those two functions
you can see that 2.1ⁿ will outgrow this part here, 2ⁿ(n²), so it is a correct bound
but it is not the best possible one
because the best possible one would be 2ⁿ(n²) and not 2.1ⁿ, which grows much faster.
So, as you can see, O notation is simply about looking at which part of the function grows
the fastest and then it's a very convenient way of actually describing the growth of that function while
ignoring details that are a bit distracting and
not necessary for the analysis that we are going to do in this course.
Now, there's one final note I should make.
Some people instead of writing f(n) € O(g(n)) also write f(n) = O(g(n)) and sometimes but this is
not very common people will also write it as if it were a subset.
So they would use the symbol here and say subset contained in O(g(n)).
This here is probably the most correct way to state it because O(g(n)) is actually
a set of functions if you were to consider it mathematically.
But this one appear = O(g(n)) is also a very common one that you can also find in many
scientific papers and even teaching books.